herzlich willkommen ja mein heutiger
gast macht zwar keine musik in der
ökonomie aber ist eher sowas wie ein
rockstar dollar bietet gilt das weltweit
wichtigste ökonomen zum soziale
ungleichheit geht und sein buch das
kapital im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
wurde in 40 sprachen übersetzt verkaufte
sich weltweit über zweieinhalb millionen
mal und war der versuch zu zeigen warum
sich die schere zwischen arm und reich
immer weiter öffnet jetzt legt der
französische ökonom nach mit seinem
neuen buch kapital und die ideologie
dass er hier in zürich vorgestellt hat
auf einladung des schweizerischen
instituts für ausland forschung
darin fordert der drastische maßnahmen
etwa dass milliardäre bis zu 90 prozent
ihres vermögens abgeben sollen
darüber müssen wir reden herzlich
willkommen
danke ja was haben sie denn gegen
milliardär persönlich rein gar nichts
aber es stellt sich die frage der
verhältnismäßigkeit die reichsten
milliardäre wie bill gates of base und
mein landsmann bernard arnault aus der
luxuswaren industrie besitzen je
ungefähr 100 milliarden vor zehn jahren
besaßen die reichsten milliardäre je
etwa 30 milliarden fünf jahre davor
waren es 5 milliarden wie hoch soll das
noch steigen die wachstumsraten in
europa und den usa aber auch der
globalen wirtschaft liegen weit unter
diesem vermögenszuwachs eine
gesellschaft kann durchaus reiche arme
und angehörige der mittelklasse umfassen
alle sollten aber etwa im selben umfang
zulegen können angesichts des
übermäßigen anstiegs der obersten
vermögen stellt sich die frage wie viel
ungleichheit hinnehmbar ist
in meinem buch kapital und geologie
untersuche ich wie die verschiedenen
gesellschaften im verlauf der geschichte
versucht haben einen guten kompromiss zu
finden
das gesunde maß an gleichheit oder eben
ungleichheit sie sagen dieses gesunde
maß ist überschritten heute und ich
möchte das mal verdeutlichen wir möchten
jetzt in gesprächen wissen über
ungleichheit sprechen über die ursachen
und folgen und diese pre mobilen
menschen symbolisieren jetzt für uns die
reichsten zehn prozent der
weltbevölkerung und ich möchte mal
anhand von diesem tisch ihr zeigen wie
viel die besitzen angenommen dieser
ganze tisch wäre das gesamtvermögen der
welt dann hätten diese zehn werden so
viel von diesem tisch besitzen bis zu
diesen strich und die restlichen 90
prozent hätten nur ungefähr 20 prozent
des gesamten vermögens und wenn man eine
person heraus greift zum beispiel diese
hier
dann gilt für die dass die ungefähr den
händen tisch hat also das reichste
prozent der bevölkerung besitzt ungefähr
die hälfte des gesamten vermögens so das
sind die zahlen ungefähr jetzt ist die
frage was ist eigentlich so schlimm
daran ist es diese ungleichheit selbst
oder sind es die folgen die
gesellschaftlichen oder ist es die art
und weise wie diese ungleichheit
zustande kommt nun es ist all das
klar ist aber dass jede gesellschaft ihr
maß an gleichheit oder ungleichheit
legitimieren muss
dies ist auch das thema meines buches
jede gesellschaft muss ihren
ungleichheiten einen sinn geben
die eliten können sich nicht damit
begnügen zu sagen wir sind reich ihr
seid arm so ist es nun mal
es braucht mehr als das wenn die reichen
sagen wir sind zwar reich und ihr seid
arm das dient aber der innovation und
fördert die gesellschaftliche stabilität
dann müssen solche rechtfertigungen eine
gewisse plausibilität
haben und es müssen grenzen genannt
werden bis wohin die ungleichheit noch
akzeptabel ist nicht interessiert jetzt
mal sie sind ein großer kritiker der
ungleichheit was würden sie sagen ist
denn die positivste eigenschaft von
ungleichheit nun die menschen
unterscheiden sich komplette gleichheit
wäre sinnlos und sie wird nirgendwo
angestrebt alle gesellschaften kennen
ein bestimmtes maß an sozialer
schichtung weil die menschen sich für
unterschiedliche dinge entscheiden
eine andere berufswahl treffen
verschiedene geschmäcker und fähigkeiten
haben sich nicht zum gleichen berufen
fühlen oder weil man glaubt es brauche
bestimmte anreize zur motivation
es gibt immer ein gewisses maß an
ungleichheit aber die frage ist wie weit
geht man damit jede gesellschaft
versucht aus der eigenen erfahrung zu
lernen und über bestimmte experimente
die ungleichheiten zu reduzieren oder
manchmal auch zu erhöhen
ich bin optimistisch dass man
langfristig aus der geschichte lernt
auch wenn dieser lernprozess nicht immer
linear verläuft und rückschritte
durchaus vorkommen global sieht man aber
langfristig einen trend zu mehr
gleichheit mit äußerst positiven folgen
zu mehr sozialer mobilität und über den
zugang zur bildung und gesundheit zu
persönlicher entfaltung aber auch zu
mehr wirtschaftlicher prosperität
geführt dieser langfristige trend zu
mehr gerechtigkeit und weniger
ungleichheit kann und muss weitergehen
durch und ist eine realität wolken sind
wie man sieht schon sie beschäftigen
sich seit einigen jahren jahrzehnten mit
dem thema ungleichheit in beiden büchern
hier
sie sind heute professor an der pariser
hochschule für sozialwissenschaften und
und dann der paris school of economics
und seit ihrer doktorarbeit eigentlich
bei antonia zinsen
beschäftigen sie sich mit diesem thema
gab es irgendeinen moment wo sie
erkannten das ist ihr thema das ist die
wurzel ganz viele missstände die es auf
der welt gibt
gibt es irgendeine erinnerung oder ein
moment der das ausgelöst hat
ich habe begonnen in der geschichte zu
forschen weil ich merkte dass die
historischen quellen bisher nicht
genutzt wurden
und steuer statistiken die für die
ökonomen zu geschichtswissenschaft lich
und für die historiker zur ökonomisch
waren ich befasste mich mit historischen
quellen material aus dem neunzehnten
jahrhundert in frankreich und dann
zusammen mit emanuel sei es für die usa
mit anthony atkinson haben wir die
forschungsarbeit dann auch auf das
vereinigte königreich ausgedehnt bis ihr
schließlich ein paar dutzend länder
weltweit untersucht haben
the world in quality data base haben wir
heutigen weltweit größte historische
datensammlung zur entwicklung der
ungleichheit in über 70 ländern
als ich mit dieser forschungsarbeit
gegangen wusste ich nicht wo häufig
stoßen wird
ich fand auch nicht in jedem land
dasselbe zwei dinge aber sind nur
aufgefallen gab es in frankreich und den
anderen europäischen ländern vor dem
ersten weltkrieg keine bewegung gegen
die ungleichheit
man hatte sich für das allgemeine
wahlrecht oder erste sozialpolitische
maßnahmen eingesetzt
aber die sehr hohe ungleichheit bei der
besitz verteilung hielt an
dabei wie sie frankreich vor 1914 als
besonders scheinheilig die elite der
dritten republik hatte die einführung
einer progressiven einkommensteuer
wiederholt verhindert erst am 15 juli
1914 wurde sie zum gesetz allerdings
nicht um schulen zu bauen sondern um den
krieg gegen deutschland zu finanzieren
erst dies führte aus der festgefahrenen
situation heraus
die französische elite hatte sich stets
des arguments bedient in frankreich
hätte ja schließlich die französische
revolution stattgefunden
womit hier gleichheit herrscht und es
anders als in aristokratischen
großbritannien oder dem autoritären
preußen auch keine einkommenssteuer
brauchen gemäss meinen historischen
quellen war aber die
vermögenskonzentration in frankreich vor
1914 so extrem wie in allen anderen
ländern
das war die erste verblüffende
feststellung aus der distanz eines
jahrhunderts zeigt sich wie scheinheilig
die dominante gruppe dann rechtfertigen
der ungleichheit war die zweite
überraschende erkenntnis von mir und
immer neue sei es war der starke anstieg
der ungleichheit in den usa seit den
80er jahren
wir haben das nicht sofort gemerkt in
unserer ersten studie die 2003
veröffentlicht wurde endete stellen
erfassung 1998 bis dahin zeigte sich nur
ein begrenzter entsteht darf ich ein
unterbrechen wir haben eine grafik die
das zeigt die die vermögensverteilung
zeigt und die ungleichheit im
zwanzigsten jahrhundert und wir schauen
mal ganz kurz haben wir sehen dass das
danach in den nachkriegsjahren nach
unten geht und danach wieder wieder
ansteigt man sieht hier der anteil der
reichsten zehn privat am gesamten
privatvermögen violet ist die usa und
rosa europa und man sieht dass sinkt und
steigt dann ab den 80er 90er jahren
wieder an genauso wie sie das jetzt
beschrieben haben interessant ist da zu
sehen dass die ungleichheit heute ja gar
nicht so groß ist im vergleich zu früher
wo sie haben recht langfristig
verringert sich die
vermögensungleichheit das ist auch die
positive botschaft meines buches vor
allem in bezug auf europa
in den usa steigt die ungleichheit er
wieder an
aber auch dort ist sie geringer als am
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
dieser langfristige trend ist eine
realität
ich möchte aber gleichzeitig auf etwas
anderes verweisen
der anteil am gesamtvermögen der ärmsten
50 prozent der bevölkerung in europa und
den usa würde in der grafik nur etwa
fünf prozent ausmachen
selbst heute besitzen also die reichsten
zehn prozent bis zu 65 prozent des
gesamtvermögens die ärmsten 50 prozent
hingegen also fünfmal so viele menschen
besitzen nur einen sehr kleinen teil des
gesamtvermögens
damit stimmt beides trotz der
langfristigen reduktion der ungleichheit
bleiben sehr starke ungleichheiten
bestehen die mehrheit der schweizer
bevölkerung die ärmsten 50 prozent oder
sogar zwei drittel der ärmsten schweizer
besitzen fast nichts
die kinder der einkommensschwachen
bevölkerung oder der mittelklasse werden
auch nichts erben
sie haben fast kein vermögen somit darf
man die langfristige verringerung der
ungleichheit nicht überbewerten
die realität ist komplex es gibt
gleichzeitig eine langfristige reduktion
der ungleichheit in einer nach wie vor
sehr in egalitären welt und in ihrem
ersten buch dem weltbestseller das
kapital im einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert
liefern sie so was wie eine erklärung
dieser ansteigenden ungleichheiten und
sie sagen da der grund dafür ist das
sozusagen die reichen immer reicher
werden dass die kapitalrendite
irgendwann größer wird als das
wirtschaftswachstum
jetzt müssen sie mir das erklären oder
wie würden sie das jemandem erklären der
von wirtschaft über wenig ahnung hat
ich betone vor allem dass die
kapitalrendite auf den größten vermögen
und anlage portfolien das
wirtschaftswachstum übertrifft und sehr
viel höher ist als die kapitalrendite
auf durchschnitts oder gar kleinfeld
wenn sie also 5000 schweizer franken auf
ihrem bankkonto haben profitieren sie
weit weniger als wenn sie über eine
finanzportfolio von fünf milliarden
verfügen
dies zeigen die vermögensbewertung von
milliardären oder die sehr viel besser
dokumentierten renditen der capital
stiftungen der großen amerikanischen
oder internationalen universitäten
ich weiß in meinem buch nach dass solche
vermögen die sich auf dutzende
milliarden belaufen können
kapitalrenditen von sieben acht oder gar
neun prozent pro jahr realisieren
nach abzug der inflation und sämtliche
verwaltungskosten soll die erträge
liegen weit über dem wirtschaftswachstum
dieser sachverhalt ist kein naturgesetz
sondern ergibt sich aus einer gewollten
gestaltung des internationalen
finanzsystems und aus einem
internationalen rechtsrahmen der den
zugang zu bestimmten anlage und
finanzprodukten reguliert so stehen
hochspezialisierte finanzderivate über
rohstoffe die an der börse von hongkong
gehandelt werden kleinsparern mit 5000
schweizer franken nicht offen
dafür braucht es schon sehr viel geld
dieser rechtsrahmen erlaubt auch einen
freien kapitalverkehr ohne eine
gemeinsame besteuerung und ohne
jeglichen informationsaustausch über die
effektiven besitzverhältnisse damit
entziehen sich die größten unternehmen
oder anleger ihren steuerverpflichtungen
die bei der mittelklasse und der ärmeren
bevölkerung anfallen
ein solches rechts und wirtschaftssystem
ist nichts was vom himmel gefallen wäre
das ist irre hauptthese im neuen buch
wurde dass sie sagen die ungleichheit
ist eben kein naturgesetz ist nicht
irgendwie ein wirtschafts gesetz oder
sowas sondern sie ist politisch
hergestellt gewollt ein eine erzählung
auch die wird gerechtfertigt so was wie
ein narrativ dass in unseren köpfen drin
ist was sind denn was ist dieses
wichtigste narrativ hat jetzt wie wird
ungleichheit heute gerechtfertigt oder
seit den 80er und 90er jahren
möglicherweise stehen wir heute an einer
wegscheide zwischen verschiedenen
visionen
man hat die lehren aus der ersten hälfte
des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts vergessen
als die in egalitäre welt des
neunzehnten und frühen zwanzigsten
jahrhunderts mit ihrer politischen
sozialen und wirtschaftlichen
instabilität zu finanzkrisen und
sozialen konflikten führte und
letztendlich auch zum erster und zweiter
weltkrieg zur oktoberrevolution und so
krise der 30er jahre
diese abfolge äußerst gewaltsamer
ereignisse von 1914 bis 1945 sind
größtenteils das resultat einer extrem
großen ungleichheit der gesellschaften
vor 1914
diese lehren scheinen heute vergessen zu
sein
im gegensatz zu der zeit zwischen 1950
und 1980
damals war man immer im bann dieser
erschütterung
der versuch die wirtschaft und das
kapitalistische system in ein regelwerk
einzubetten
ziel war ein sozialdemokratischer
kompromiss mit einem sozialen
sicherheitssysteme einer regulierung der
finanzmärkte und des arbeitsrechts sowie
progressive steuern in jedes jeweilige
wirtschaftssystem eingebettet ist wie
gesagt gerieten diese lehren in den 80er
und 90er jahren etwas in vergessenheit
warum warum passiert dieser wandel
menschliche gesellschaften haben oft ein
kurzes gedächtnis
genau deshalb ist geschichte wichtig
weil man die dinge in ihrem licht
untersuchen kann
viele haben zb vergessen dass ein sehr
bewusster versuch die ungleichheit im
kapitalistischen system zu reduzieren
im zwanzigsten jahrhundert sehr gut
funktioniert hat die usa der globale
führer des damaligen kapitalistischen
wirtschaftssystems hat man zwischen 1930
und 1980 einen spitzensteuersatz von 81
prozent
offenbar brachte dieser das
amerikanische kapitalistischen system
nicht zum verschwinden im gegenteil es
hat ja ein halbes jahrhundert lang
bestand erwähnt man das heute hört man
das ist der branche wichtig wie in der
sowjetunion sowie wachstum durch
wirtschaftswachstum war sogar noch groß
in dieser zeit sagen sie
es war nie höher
diese historischen daten zeigen dass
einkommensteuersätze von 80 prozent auf
den sehr hohen einkommen das
wirtschaftswachstum in keiner weise
gehemmt haben eben weil es nur auf den
wirklich hohen einkommen und vermögen
angewandt wurde
das ließ eine zumutbare ungleichheit
zwischen den arbeitern und im kader
mitarbeitern und managern zu eine
exzessive ungleichheit wurde damit aber
ausgeschlossen
dieses system ermöglichte investitionen
in infrastrukturprojekte und bildung und
es resultierte in einem sozialen konsens
über das die unter und mittelklasse über
ihre steuern auch ihren beitrag zu einem
neuen sozialsystem leisten müssten
aber weil die reichsten einen noch
größeren beitrag leisten dass sozial
akzeptabel
heute aber hat angesichts der
steuerflucht der reichsten die mittel-
und unterschicht das gefühl hintergangen
zu werden
das stellt die steuer willigkeit und den
ganzen gesellschaftsvertrag in frage
deshalb schlage ich vor sich diesen
zeitraum noch einmal genau anzusehen
viele historische daten zeigen wie gut
dieser versuch funktioniert hat
historische argumente sind intellektuell
anspruchsvoll was auch erklärt weshalb
diese lehre vergessen gegangen ist
wenn ich zum beispiel donald trump vom
wert dieser historischen vergleiche
erzählen und ihnen sagen würde er müsse
sich die wachstumszahlen der 1900 50er
und 60er jahre ansehen dann hat er
spätestens da aufgehört mir zuzuhören
er wird mir sagen die geschichte ist mir
egal mit meiner intuition als
geschäftsmann weiß ich was es 2020
braucht aber ich denke man sollte sich
nicht auf das niveau von donald trump
gegeben
allerdings finde ich die größten
skeptiker dieses progressiven
spitzensteuersatzes sollten sich bereit
erklären sich die historischen fakten
und daten anzusehen und sich dann eine
eigene meinung bilden
aber es ist ja auch immer schwierig
lehren aus der geschichte zu ziehen das
weiß man ja und nach zwei weltkriegen
passieren hat andere dinge es gibt auch
den vorwurf dass es steuerflucht gab in
dieser zeit zum beispiel oder dass man
das nicht wiederherstellen kann
das heißt es sich doch schwierig lehrern
also eine zeit zu ziehen und das sind
ins heute denn hier ins hier und jetzt
zu übertragen
ich sehe uns ansehen die vision ist es
ist schwierig aber wir haben ja nichts
anderes wenn man sich weigert lehren aus
der vergangenheit zu ziehen plaudert
teil jeder so ein bisschen drauf los sie
sprachen die steuerflucht zu der zeit
aber es stimmt nicht dass die
ungleichheit damals so groß war wie
heute es war nicht so dass die leute
ebenso reich waren und keine steuern
zeiten es gab eine wirkliche reduktion
der ungleichheit
besonders interessant ist die erfahrung
der usa
der vergleich mit europa wo die
wirtschaft nach dem krieg großen
nachholbedarf hat er macht den vergleich
mit heute tatsächlich schwierig in den
usa lag die wachstumsrate des
nationaleinkommens pro kopf der
bevölkerung von 1950 bis 1990 bei
durchschnittlich 2,2 prozent pro jahr
das ist keine außerordentliche phase
zwischen 1910 und 1950 lag die
wachstumsrate mit 2 prozent auch etwa
dort und 1870 bis 1910 lag sie bei 1,9
prozent
die periode von 1950 bis 1990 war also
leicht besser aber sehr ähnlich
nach den rängen jahren allerdings von
1990 bis 2020 fiel das wachstum auf 1,1
prozent pro jahr
das versprechen über steuersenkungen für
unternehmer und milliardäre die
wirtschaft zu beleben wurde also nicht
erfüllt will man der theorie des trickle
down effekt unter reagan glauben müsste
man zeigen können dass das wachstum ohne
regen eigentlich um den faktor 4 zurück
gegangen wäre dank regen aber nur um den
faktor 2 aus historischer perspektive
kann dies aber nicht bestätigt werden
der wachstumsrückgang sei den regen
jahren geht vor allem auf geringere
investitionen ins bildungssystem zurück
der wohlstand der usa beruhte eigentlich
immer auf ihrem großen bildungs
vorsprung gegenüber europa bis mitte des
in den 80ern und 90ern wurde dieser aber
preisgegeben das narrativ der 80er jahre
wonach wachstum auf ungleichheit und den
vermögens milliardären beruhe hätte er
stimmen können unter berufung auf die
geschichte muss man aber schlussfolgern
dass vielmehr eine gewisse
chancengleichheit in der bildung
wirtschaftliche prosperität bringt dank
einem erziehungssystem das in die breite
bevölkerung investiert
sie sagen sogar noch es hatte noch
schlimmere folgen aus nur wenig wachstum
nämlich die gegenwärtige krise der
demokratie der populismus die
reaktionären bewegungen der
nationalismus trump praxis weiter habe
damit zu tun mit dieser verschärften
ungleichheit die seite und 80er jahren
wieder zugenommen hat
so ist es in erster linie ein
wirtschaftliches phänomen zu sagen die
abstiegsängste der mittelschicht die
zunehmende ungleichheit das wäre ihre
erklärung für den gegenwärtig zu
beobachtenden populismus und
nationalismus das erstarken des
populismus und insbesondere des
nationalismus bei der politischen
rechten geht wesentlich auf ein gefühl
das vergessen worden science der
arbeiterschaft und der mittelklasse
zurückgibt
die usa und das vereinigte königreich
sind die beiden länder mit dem größten
anstieg der ungleichheit seit den 80er
jahren
trump und der praxis sind so gesehen
kein zufall
es gab unter reagan und thatcher das
versprechen auf wohlstand für alle durch
die globalisierung und den breiten
wettbewerb der volkswirtschaften die
arbeiterschaft und die mittelklasse der
usa und des vereinigten königreichs
haben davon aber nie etwas gemerkt so
sucht frau ab heute 30 jahre später die
schuld bei den mexikanern den chinesen
in den europäer
die nicht genug für die nato bezahlt
sind alle anderen bei dem rexit
anhängern im vereinigten königreich war
es ähnlich
los waren es da die polnischen arbeiter
die nationalistische rhetorik ist
größtenteils das resultat der steigenden
ungleichheit
es hat keinen versuch zur
neuorganisation der globalisierung
gegeben von der breitere
gesellschaftsschichten hätten
profitieren können
die welle des nationalismus hat
mittlerweile ganz europa erfasst
so haben in deutschland die sogenannten
mitte rechts kräfte vor ein paar wochen
mit der rechtsaußenpartei für eine
regionalregierung gestimmt in meinem
heimatland frankreich ist die extreme
rechte mit leben seit jahrzehnten sehr
stark wenn man diese bedrohung nicht
ernst nimmt ist die demokratie wie wir
sie kennen aber auch die globalisierung
gefährdet das wäre ein sehr großer
fehler und ein großes risiko für unsere
gesellschaft
pressebox unfrei kritisiert pike die im
letzten jahr war hier jemand bei uns gas
änderung haben ist der amerikanische
politologe francis fukuyama er vertritt
eine andere these er glaubt nämlich es
geht weniger um die wirtschaftlichen
abstiegsängste und um die ungleichheit
sondern eher um kulturelle verlustängste
wir hören mal ganz kurz hinter den
wirtschaftlichen gründen steckt oft eine
kulturelle dimension wenn ich meine
stelle verliere oder weniger verdiene
als mein vater sehe ich dies als
statusverlust an
schuld daran sind dann schnell einmal
die fremden der internationale
wettbewerb oder die migranten die ins
land strömen arbeitsplätze wegnähmen und
den sozialstaat untergraben
in den nullerjahren kam es zu grossen
subprime hypothekenkrise in den usa 2008
und zur euro krise unter diesem versagen
der großen banken und der eliten lippen
vor allem die einfachen menschen
normalerweise ist
ist der nährboden für linkspopulistische
kräfte tatsächlich ist in den usa aber
die tea party aufgekommen und in europa
profitierten die migrations feindlichen
parteien mit ihrem straff
nationalistischen und gegen die eu
gerichteten kurs
dies zeugt davon dass die kulturelle
dimension und fragen der identität
wichtiger sind als die wirtschaftliche
ungleichheit die wir heute beobachten ja
was halten sie von dieser analyse vom
wifo ja gesagt hat findet der
wirtschaftliche verlust eine kulturelle
interpretation vorgeschlagen werden
kulturelle lösungen die auf der
identität griff ich denke aber nicht
dass ein solcher lösungsansatz wie er
von trump oder im kontext des brh exit
vorgeschlagen wird die probleme wirklich
beheben wird der anstieg der
ungleichheit wird weitergehen befördert
durch die nationalistische abschottung
und den stärkeren konkurrenzkampf der
länder steuerpolitik erschöpft sich
darin die steuerlast für die
multinationalen unternehmen oder für
milliardäre wie ihn weiter zu senken
er wollte sogar die erbschaftsteuer für
milliardäre vollständig aufheben
hilft das der mittelklasse oder der
arbeiterklasse die durch die teuren
universitäten oder wegen der ausufernden
gesundheitskosten stark verschuldet sind
diese schuldenkrise müsse über eine
umverteilung also über wirtschaftliche
mechanismen gelöst werden der auf
identität und nationalismus bezogene
diskurs ist einfacher als die lösungen
für die ich eintrete meine vorschläge
eines sozialen föderalismus und eines
partizipativen sozialismus erfordern ein
komplexen diskurs die besinnung auf die
landesgrenzen und die identität ist
dagegen sehr einfach
weil alternativen fehlen hat dieser
ansatz heute aufwand ohne aber die
großen herausforderungen unserer zeit
den anstieg der ungleichheit oder die
klimaerwärmung zu lösen
man wird also lieber früher als später
zurückfinden müssen zu internationalen
und egalitären lösungen diese
entwicklung hat bereits begonnen
im sozialdemokratischen flügel der
demokraten in den usa läuft eine
diskussion über umverteilung der
vielleicht nicht sofort auf 7
aber im laufe der zeit den diskurs und
die vorschläge zur minderung der
ungleichheit beeinflussen wird
mit dem tribeca tross vor melodie school
die proposition diesem feld realisiert
haben sie die demokraten haben chancen
im herbst gegen trank zu gewinnen und
wir müssen sie ihre botschaft verkauft
damit das klappen könnte ich denke
bernie sanders oder elisabeth dürften
zwar durchaus ein bisschen jünger sein
trotzdem hätten gerade sie die jungen
und die arbeiterklasse motivieren können
an die urne zu gehen und die demokraten
zu wählen wenn sich die beiden nicht
gemüt bestimmte vorschläge von bernie
sanders oder elizabeth warren
aufzunehmen besteht das risiko dass
trump wiedergewählt wird 2016 hat
hillary clinton als kandidatin der
demokraten zum ersten mal unter den
meist verdienen denn am besten
abgeschnitten nachdem die demokraten
schon seit jahrzehnten bei den leuten
mit den höchsten schulabschlüssen am
meisten zuspruch erhielten gelang es
ihnen zum ersten mal auch die reichen
anzusprechen
es hat also eine komplette verschiebung
gegeben
die demokraten traditionell hort der
arbeiter und der einkommensschwachen
schichten sind nun plötzlich die partei
der gut verdienen die frage ist also ob
man so weiterfahren und tram und im
nationalistischen lager das feld
überlassen will
in europa steht man heute vor derselben
herausforderung
ich möchte gerne mit denen jetzt ein
bisschen weg von der politik hin zur
philosophie ihre beiden bücher tragen
nämlich titel die erinnern an karl marx
die briefe ideologie und auch kapital
neben darauf bezug sie grenzen sich aber
immer wieder dezidiert ab von marx was
wo ist er denn falsch gelegen
der deutsche philosoph und es gibt
wirklich viele unterschiede zwischen
meinen büchern und den von karl marx
erstens einmal stützt sich meine
sozialwissenschaftliche studie als
empirische historische forschungsarbeit
auf eine umfangreiche datensammlung
das buch umfasst 169 grafiken und
tabellen
so etwas gibt es bei marx nicht das
alleine ist ein großer unterschied
ich will karl marx daraus keinen vorwurf
machen er natürlich war das sammeln von
daten im neunzehnten jahrhundert viel
schwieriger aber er hätte ruhig etwas
weniger abstrakt und theoretisch dafür
ein bisschen empirischer und
geschichtswissenschaftliche vorgehen
können
aber wie gesagt es war viel schwieriger
die daten zusammen wichtiger als die
datenerhebung ist die rückschau auf das
zwanzigste jahrhundert
ich blicke zurück auf 150 jahre
historische erfahrung seit karl marx und
das ändert alles weil im zwanzigsten
jahrhundert so viel geschafft
es gab die katastrophe des sowjetischen
die erfolge und am ende der periode auch
die grenzen der sozialdemokratie eine
historische wirtschaftliche politische
und philosophische reflexion auf folgt
auf der grundlage dieser erfahrungen
ich weiß nicht was karl marx über die
heutige kommunistischer parteien china
über den sowjetischen kommunismus oder
über die sozialdemokratie denken würde
ich habe das glück heute zu leben und
diese erfahrungen nutzen zu können
bei der allgemeinen
geschichtsbetrachtung besteht der
hauptunterschied sowohl darin dass ich
dem kampf der ideen und der ideologien
mehr gewicht beimesse als dem
klassenkampf natürlich ist der klassen
konflikt sehr wichtig gerade erst
kürzlich hat man in chile dem libanon
oder mit den chinesen in frankreich
soziale bewegungen gesehen die ihre
forderungen nach sozialer gerechtigkeit
in die straßen getragen haben dies wird
es auch weiterhin der klassen konflikt
wird weiter eine wichtige rolle in der
geschichte spielen ist aber für sich
alleine noch kein politisches programm
aus ihm allein entsteht keine theorie zu
besitz und vermögen kein ideales
steuersystem kein ideales bildungssystem
dafür braucht es ideen und ideologien
marx und bestimmte marxistische theorie
nieren darin zu glauben dass der
klassenkampf zu einer theorie des
handelns führt und dass es ausreichen
würde das kapitalistische system des
privatbesitzes zu stürzen um dann am
nächsten tag ein emanzipatorisches
modell des kollektiv besitzers zu haben
man weiß was daraus entstanden ist
angesichts dieser erfahrung gilt es die
frage eines anderen besitz systems ernst
zu nehmen
das sich vom kapitalistischen modell
unterscheidet gleichzeitig aber stark
dezentral organisiert ist
deshalb schlage ich am ende des buchs
das modell eines partizipativen
sozialismus vor
das ist ein extrem dezentrales system
mit mehr vertretungs rechte der arbeiter
und angestellte einem zugang zum
allgemeinen eigentum für alle
gesellschaftlichen gruppen
wir haben ja vorhin gesehen dass die
ernsten 50 prozent nichts besitzen
deshalb braucht es einen breiteren
zugang zu kleinen privatvermögen das
sind alles große unterschied zu karl
marx genauso sie sagen es ganz am ende
in ihrem buch in ihrem neuen buch machen
sie ganz konkrete vorschläge und
forderungen etwa stark progressive
steuern auf erbschaften einkommen und
vermögen aber auch so etwas wie ein star
zerbe oder ein startkapital für die
ganze bevölkerung von etwa 120.000 euro
dass man dann bekommt wenn man 25 jährig
geworden ist auch mehr betriebliche
mitbestimmung und so weiter sie haben
eines erwähnt was interessant ist und
was ein marxistischer gedanke ist
nämlich das eigentum und das müssen wir
ganz neu denken sagen sie sie sagen
schlagen vor wir brauchen ein eigentum
auf zeit können sie das erläutern was
das heißt wir umdenken lösten in sachen
eigentum so propos sie dulden
ich schlage vor dass rein
kapitalistischen system zu ersetzen
durch ein system des partizipativen
sozialismus er auf zwei hauptpfeiler
gründet einerseits die mitbestimmung die
belegschaft eines unternehmens sollte
über weitgehende stimmrechte verfügen
in deutschland haben die
arbeitnehmervertreter einen
stimmenanteil von 50 prozent in den
aufsichts und betriebsräten der
großunternehmen in schweden sind es 35
prozent gilt dort aber auch für kleine
rote denkbar wäre ein stimmrecht von 50
prozent in sämtlichen unternehmen dank
der mitsprache gelang es die
arbeitnehmer besser in die langfristigen
investitionsstrategien der unternehmen
einzubinden
hier könnte man noch weiter gehen und
zum beispiel die stimmrechte von einzel
aktionären begrenzen so dass kein
aktionär in großunternehmen über mehr
als zehn prozent der stimmen
sie verfügt jeder soll sich einbringen
kann
es ist schlicht nicht sinnvoll bestens
ausgebildete angestellte ingenieure und
kadermitglieder von wirtschafts
entscheiden auszuschließen
zu denen sie etwas beitragen können die
idee dass nur die familienmitglieder des
firmengründers oder eingeheiratete das
recht haben an den firmen entscheidungen
teilzuhaben entspricht nicht der
realität unserer vor ragend gebildeten
gesellschaft es braucht eine zirkulation
der macht und besitz verteilung
ich nenne das sozial eigentum mit einer
starken arbeitnehmervertretung der
zweite hauptpfeiler ist das eigentum auf
zeit
die idee dass besitzer großer vermögen
der gesellschaft regelmäßig einen teil
ihres besitzes zurückgeben müssen
ich will eine gesellschaft in der jeder
und jede über ein vernünftiges maß an
eigentum verfügen kann und zugriff
erhält auf einige hunderttausend euro
in einzelnen fällen auf einige millionen
und ein sehr erfolgreicher unternehmer
vielleicht auf 10 oder 20 millionen
[Musik]
die geschichtsdaten die mir vorliegen
zeigen dass es nichts bringt in einzelne
milliardäre 10 50 oder gar 100
milliarden besitzen wenn jemand mit 30
reich geworden ist weil er eine gute
idee oder vielleicht auch einfach glück
hatte oder beides heißt das nicht dass
er oder sie bis 50 70 oder 90 alle macht
auf sich vereinen und sämtliche firmen
entscheidungen alleine treffen soll die
tausende zehntausende oder manchmal
hunderttausende menschen betreffen
solche entscheidungen sind zu komplex
als dass sie bei einer einzelnen person
konzentriert sein sollten diese art der
heiligsprechung der milliardär
oder anderer personen mit großer
machtfülle für ihr unternehmen oder für
branchen oder technologien die wichtig
sind für die ganze welt entspricht einem
monarchistischen verständnis der
wirtschaft der schlicht nicht an die
heutigen verhältnisse angepasst ist
ihre eigene vorschläge sind auch sehr
utopisch und leben wahrscheinlich auch
das ganze system also wenn man den
milliardären fast das ganze gesamte
vermögen weg nimmt bis zu 90 prozent
was hat man dafür einen anreiz überhaupt
noch sich wie anzustrengen und versuchen
im wettbewerb zu gewinnen
sie sind opfer einer ideologischen
illusion
die meisten unternehmer in der schweiz
in deutschland oder frankreich sind
keine milliardäre wenn es ihnen gelingt
ein paar millionen oder ein paar dutzend
millionen schweizer franken auf die
seite zu legen ist das bereits ein
gewaltiger erfolg
es sind diese leute die die wirtschaft
in gang halten die idee dass es leute
braucht die 10 50 oder 100 milliarden
besitzen und die die arbeit einstellen
würden wenn sie nur noch eine milliarde
anstatt 100 milliarden hätten bei der
ökonomische anreiz in viele entspricht
mit verlaub nicht den gesunden
menschenverstand und vor allem
berücksichtigt sie nicht die lehren aus
der geschichte
es gab in den usa im jahr 2000 oder 2010
sehr viel mehr milliardäre als in den
70ern oder 80ern gab es aber mehr
innovation mehr produktivitätsgewinne
mehr wachstum bei löhnen und erträgen
das wachstum war nur halb so groß das
narrativ dass ein solches anreizsystem
mehr wohlstand für die allgemeinheit
schafft hätte ja wahr sein können
rein theoretisch ist alles was sie sagen
ja möglich auf grundlage der
historischen erfahrung über die wir
verfügen muss ich sagen tut mir leid
aber das glaube ich wirklich
aber wie wollen sie das oben setzen das
müsste man ja global umsetzen weil wenn
ein land das machen würde würden
wahrscheinlich die leute abwandern und
soweit sie brauchen wahrscheinlich eine
globale idee wie diese maßnahmen
durchgesetzt werden
nein überhaupt nicht und ich kann auf
die demokratische
präsidentschaftskandidat und die beiden
kandidaten waren und centers verweisen
ist rechtsprofessoren inhabers sicher
also keine juristische karriere
bernie sanders wäre im europäischen
politik spektrum wohl ein eher
pragmatischer sozialdemokrat sie beide
vereinigten fast die hälfte der stimmen
der ersten vorwahlen auf sich darunter
die überwiegende mehrheit der unter 50
jährigen wobei senders und warren unter
der altersgruppe der 18 bis 34 jährigen
viel beliebter sind als balsam
sie gilt es auch im weiteren verlauf bei
der stange zu halten
sowohl sein dass sie auch warren haben
vorgeschlagen eine bundessteuer auf dem
vermögen einzuführen es gibt in den usa
seit 1913 eine bundessteuer auf dem
einkommen und seit 1916 eine
bundessteuer auf dem erbe aber es gab
noch nie amerikaweit eine
vermögenssteuer die beiden kandidaten
haben eine vermögenssteuer von bis zu
acht prozent pro jahr für die
multimilliardäre vorgeschlagen
wer also 100 milliarden besitzt bezahlt
pro jahr acht milliarden und in zehn
jahren 80er jahren
wer die usa mit seinem vermögen
verlassen will kann das gemäß diesem
plan thoma aber er oder sie liehen
schuldet den usa dann ein eck 46 prozent
politiker und doch so dass eine solche
politik setzt natürlich einen teil der
regeln zum freien kapitalverkehr außer
kraft
aber diese regeln müssen sowieso
geändert
sie haben diese erfahrung in der schweiz
ja auch gemacht
als obama 2010 der schweiz mitteilte das
bankgeheimnis ist ja nett aber ich will
dass die schweiz mehr angaben zu den
amerikanischen steuerpflichtigen
übermittelt die konten in der schweiz
haben sagte die schweiz anfangs nein
darauf erwiderte obama wenn sie das
ablehnen verlieren die schweizer banken
die banklizenz in den usa worauf die
schweizer einlenkte die regeln zum
freien kapitalverkehr entsprechend
keinem naturgesetz sie sind nicht in
stein gemeißelt sie wurden zu einem
bestimmten zeitpunkt aufgestellt und sie
werden sich weiterentwickeln müssen mit
den verträgen zum freien kapitalverkehr
ohne behördliche regulierung hat man in
den 80er jahren eine art heiliges recht
geschaffen vermögen in einem land zu
öffnen oft unter inanspruchnahme der
öffentlichen infrastrukturen dieses
landes des bildungs und rechtssystems
und des breiten fachwissen und dann auf
einen knopf zu drücken um das geld in
ein anderes land überweisen wo niemand
mehr weiß was wem wo gehört das stellt
man dann 30 jahre später erstaunt fest
und zwingt die ärmsten und die
mittelklasse die zeche zu bezahlen weil
die nicht wecken
das führt dazu dass die menschen die
globalisierung zu hassen
ich komme zurück auf ihre frage wie man
es in einem einzelnen land anstellt mir
scheint der vorschlag von warren und
senders absolut glaubhaft das könnte
funktionieren
und ich glaube eines tages werden die
usa das auch praktizieren ich hoffe dass
beiden intelligent genug ist den
vorschlag aufzugreifen
das wäre eine gute lösung für die usa
und würde helfen junge und
einkommensschwache bevölkerungsteile an
die urnen zu bringen die eine
umverteilung
und eine reduktion der ungleichheit in
den usa wollen wenn er nicht sofort
umgesetzt wird dann eben später
sie haben sicher festgestellt dass
selbst in deutschland die
sozialdemokratische partei die
wiedereinführung einer vermögenssteuer
verlangt was vor fünf oder zehn jahren
nicht der fall war
die debatte über die vermögenssteuer
entwickelt sich sehr rasch sie haben
anfang des gesprächs gesagt nicht jede
ungleichheit ist ungerechtfertigt das
möchte ich mit ihnen noch kurz darüber
reden was denn die kriterien sind wann
eine ungleichheit gut ist oder
gerechtfertigt es gibt ja von dem
amerikanischen philosophen john ross in
seiner theorie der gerechtigkeit die
überlegung dass ungleichheiten dann
gerechtfertigt sind wenn sie allen
zugute kommen das heißt wenn sie dafür
sorgen dass es den ärmsten ein bisschen
besser geht wäre das ein guter grund
ungleichheiten zu akzeptieren oder ist
das auch eine form von ideologie ja ich
gehe auf theoretischer ebene mit den
grundsätzen von john rawls 1 er bleibt
aber mit seinen grundsätzen bei der
reinen theorie und stellt keine
untersuchungen zum akzeptablen maß an
gleichheit oder ungleichheit an
so werden seine grundsätze oft dazu
verwendet jede ungleichheit zu
rechtfertigen da wird es problematisch
so sagen das prinzip ist gut aber die
realität ist anders und das wird
instrumentalisiert ungleichheit
genau deshalb braucht es einen
historischen ansatz als den von john
walls ich bin einverstanden mit dem
grundsatz dieser ist sehr gut so richtig
interessant wird es aber erst wenn man
schaut was dieser in bezug auf die
steuerlast oder das maß an ungleichheit
bedeutet das ist denn auch mein ansatz
ich versuche in meinem buch zu
definieren was eine gerechte
gesellschaft ausmacht eine gerechte
gesellschaft gesteht allen weit ist
ihre rechte auf die grundlegenden
gesellschaftlichen güter zu bildung
gesundheit und ganz generell teilnahme
am wirtschaftlichen sozialen
demokratischen leben demokratie
ungleichheiten können gerechtfertigt
sein wenn sie den allgemeinen zugang zu
den grundrechten verbessern
dieser grundsatz ist dem von john rawls
nicht unähnlich aber ich versuche die
grenzen von gleichheit und ungleichheit
historisch auszuloten
dabei stelle ich fest dass man das mass
an ungleichheit wie es heute vor allem
in den usa aber auch in europa besteht
sehr stark reduzieren kann
ohne diesen grundsatz der gerechtigkeit
zu verletzen
das bedeutet nicht absolute gleichheit
absolute gleichheit ist nicht wünschbar
bei jeder mensch anders ist einige
werden ihre prioritäten zu setzen dass
sie möglichst viel besitzen auch in
sachen geld andere möchten ihre zeit
eher mit dingen verbringen die nicht
monetären ziel unterworfen sind diese
unterschiede zwischen den menschen sind
völlig legitim
man darf sich dieses grundsatzes aber
nicht bedienen um damit das bewahren
eines vorteils der sieger zu
rechtfertigen ein prinzip das auch immer
wieder ins spiel kommen
das ist das prinzip der leistung der
leistungsgedanken wenn gesagt wird wenn
jemand mehr leistet hatte auch anrecht
auf mehr einkommen auf melonen zb was
halten sie denn von diesem prinzip und
wie will man die wahre leistung messen
wenn man jetzt nicht sagt der markt
bestimmt was jemand geleistet hat das
ist eine illusion
jeglicher reichtum ist in seinem
ursprung immer sozial und kollektiv
verankert wir alle nutzen ein
öffentliches infrastrukturnetz und
allgemein vorhandenes wissen
bill gates hat den computer nicht
alleine erfunden tausende von computer
wissenschaftlern haben einen
forschungsbeitrag
ohne unter jeden ihrer
wissenschaftlichen artikeln
ihr scheckheft zu leben das alles wurde
ermöglicht vom wissen dass menschen über
jahrzehnte ja jahrhunderte geschaffen
haben es ist eine illusion zu glauben
man könne einen einzelnen beitrag daraus
isolieren privatbesitz ist eine
schöpfung der menschlichen gesellschaft
um sich zu organisieren
das ist nützlich um einzelne handlungen
innerhalb eines dezentralen systems zu
koordinieren
braucht es privatbesitz in vernünftiger
größe
er erlaubt dem einzelnen seine projekte
zu verfolgen so dass individuelle
persönliche ideen verwirklicht werden
können resolution legitimiert
privatbesitz für alle in einem
vernünftigen ausmaß eine exzessive
konzentration von besitzt kann damit
aber nicht gerechtfertigt werden in
privat richier wächst das glück muss ich
möchte mit ihnen gegen ende des
gesprächs noch über eine sehr dringende
frage reden nämlich über die ökologische
frage nicht so sehr über die soziale
vielleicht ist die ökologische ja auch
eine spielform der sozialen frage und da
die frage an sie ob sie der meinung sind
dass nachhaltiges ökologisches wachstum
möglich ist oder wie sie sich in dieser
frage verhalten in meinem buch lege ich
da das die themen der ungleichheit und
der klimafrage eng miteinander verbunden
sind
ich stütze mich dabei auf
forschungsarbeiten am laboratoire de
cali thema und ja an der école de caux
nomi in paris ein prozent der menschen
mit dem größten co2 emissionen stoßen
mehr aus als 50 prozent der menschen mit
dem geringsten co2 ausstoß wenn man also
nicht sehr rasch die bedeutsamen co2
emissionen an der spitze reduziert
schaffen wir die ziele nicht umgekehrt
wird man es nicht schaffen die ärmsten
50 prozent der weltbevölkerung die vor
allem in den
südlichen ländern leben zu überzeugen
ihrerseits anstrengungen zu unternehmen
wenn nicht in erster linie den reichsten
die norden leben gleiches abverlangt
wird
ohne eine reduktion der ungleichheit
gibt es also keine chance auf
energieeinsparungen
zweitens müssen wir dringend die
indikatoren für wirtschaftlichen
fortschritt ändern
das bruttoinlandsprodukt ist zum
beispiel kein guter indikator für
wirtschaftlichen fortschritt in meinen
forschungen schlage ich vor den
indikator des nationaleinkommens zu
verwenden
der vom bip nicht nur den anteil des
kapitals abzieht der ins ausland
abwandert sondern auch die kapital
entwertung insbesondere des natürlichen
kapitals nehmen wir ein beispiel wenn
sie dem boden kohlenwasserstoffe im wert
von 100 milliarden euro entnehmen und
diese auf den boden legen steigt ihr bip
um 100 milliarden
wenn sie den ozeanen fische im umfang
von 100 milliarden entnehmen und sie
beiseite legen um sie zu essen
entspricht dies einem bip-anteil von 100
milliarden vom blickwinkel des
nationaleinkommens aber sind das null
euro
weil sie so nur den bereits bestehenden
kapitalstock abgeschöpft haben wenn sie
die kohlenwasserstoffe dann auch noch
verbrennen
steigt die temperatur weltweit was das
leben auf dem planeten erschwert wenn
sie die wahren kosten aus den co2
emissionen berücksichtigen erhalten sie
sogar ein negatives nationaleinkommen
dieselben wirtschaft operation können
also ein positives bip oder ein
negatives nationaleinkommen erzeugen
die wahl der indikatoren zur messung
wirtschaftlichen fortschritt kann die
sicht auf das was getan werden muss
komplett verändern dann muss man auch
die ungleichheiten im nationaleinkommen
messen und nicht nur die gesamte
volkswirtschaftliche produktion wie beim
bip und weiter muss man natürlich auch
reine klimaindikatoren wie die co2
emissionen oder biodiversitäts
indikatoren bei 10
wenn wir die art wie wir
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
fortschritt messen nicht mehr radikal
ändern
schaffen wir es nicht zurzeit gibt es
eigentlich nur ein thema in unseren
köpfen
leider und das ist das corona virus das
derzeit die welt lahmlegt
gesundheitsgefährdend ist und die
wirtschaft auch lahmlegt können sie eine
prognose stellen wie wird dieses diese
krise ihre zahlen verändern in sachen
ungleichheit wer wird daran stärksten
darunter leiden aus wirtschaftlicher
sicht
man kann aus dieser gesundheitskrise
zumindest schon mal lernen dass wir die
regeln des wirtschafts gebarens durchaus
gemeinsam fundamental ändern können wenn
wir es für notwendig erachten so wurde
in dieser gesundheitskrise beschlossen
einen großteil der
wirtschaftsaktivitäten und des
flugverkehrs einzustellen
das ist interessant wer noch vor ein
paar wochen oder monaten sagte man müsse
den flugverkehr und die co2 emissionen
reduzieren um die klimaziele des pariser
abkommen zu erreichen bekam zu hören das
wäre aufgrund der wirtschaft und der
kosten unmöglich plötzlich geht das bei
einer epidemie die zumindest bis heute
weit weniger tote gefordert hat als die
grippe oder umweltfaktoren in verbindung
mit schlechter luftqualität jedes jahr
zehntausende menschenleben kosten
dafür ändert man nichts an den
wirtschafts regel für die
gesundheitsüberwachung sind extrem hoch
entwickelter warm und
interventionsmaßnahmen entwickelt worden
die manchmal vielleicht sogar zu weit
gehen die aber in ihrer gesamtheit wohl
gerechtfertigt sind
jetzt gilt es mechanismen zu den umwelt
und sozialen risiken wie der
ungleichheit zu entwickeln
die zwar langfristigere
risiken sind und nicht so plötzlich und
heftig auftauchen wie eine epidemie die
aber mindestens langfristig ebenso
notwendig sind ich hoffe also dass wir
diese krise entnehmen dass wir kollektiv
die wirtschaftskräfte regulieren können
und müssen
um ein soziales gleichgewicht für die
verletzlichen gesellschaften bewahren zu
können
in denen wir leben vielleicht ist das
eine lehre die wir aus dieser
schrecklichen krise ziehen können bietet
die ganz herzlichen dank für dieses
interessante gespräche ja auch ihnen
danke fürs mitdenken wäre das alles noch
genauer nachlesen möchte in einem
handsignierten buch unseres gastes
schreibt eine mail an philosophie hat
srf punkt ch wir verlosen ein exemplar
von das kapital im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert und kapital und ideologie
jetzt gleich geht es um eine andere form
der wert vermehrung nämlich darum wie
aus einem stück holz einen teil gewährt
die millionen wert hat und von der
person dieses spiel sogar als liebe des
lebens bezeichnet wird
bleiben sie also dran und ein schönes
[Musik]